first question here in the second first
question here in the second row third
seat - hey Caroline congratulations on
the game on the win again Cameron Buford
our late news observe former teammate
demar derozan
how much contact do you have and will
you be talking to him on the way back to
Toronto I mean this is all yours man
this is all yours my best friend I mean
I talk to him almost every day and it's
not about basketball is about life and
so yeah I mean I'll talk to him I
probably call him tonight and I won't
talk about that so just about what you
did in the regular regular life and
living his life living his life problem
rosh in the back all right Kyle over to
your right a rash man Danny with sports
night you guys walked off the fan of
stone face a couple of fist bumps quo in
the locker room it seemed business as
usual you guys just came in here took
two from the Warriors you're joining
meet up gonna meet up I mean serge ibaka
everybody yeah nobody you know
nice outfit worth a lot of money okay
all right pants too tight you can t sit
down
may be a question for both of you just
after the game it was kind of stone with
you just after the game it was kind of
stone face business as usual a win away
from a championship you somebody think
there would be some cause for
celebration there wasn't what's the
mindset we do nothing ever done anything
you know we we won three games you know
it's the first of four we understand
that there's a defending champs and
they're not prepared to play the next
game and that's how we're preparing
ourselves that we have to you know we
got to prepare ourselves to play to the
next game you know we haven't done
anything yet we haven't done anything
yet
Michael again on the right Serge and
Kyle
they said you first micro grains from
Sports Net surgeon spots in there and
your teammates found you and what what
opportunities does it present when Kawhi
Leonard is going off the way it did in
the third
order and and what quarter and and what
were you trying to do to kind of support
him offensively how much you try to play
basketball order we we know they were
try to take away away mm so I was just
try to play in a space and also you know
Kauai and Kyoto guys did a great job to
find me every time I was moving or
surged at half-time you'd played some
really really good defense what was the
focus coming into the third quarter and
and being able to offset that with you
know try and make some shots I guess you
know they're a really good third quarter
team and Kauai came out made two
back-to-back threes and kind of got us
jump-started a little bit you know we
know what happened at Game two and we
know that's a big that was a big part of
you know what we are learning process it
but we just continue to just keep trying
to you know stay on them stay in a
moment stay level-headed you know stay
with the game plan and understanding
what we have to do and keep working mark
on the left side of the aisle Kyle mark
Schwartz ESPN because Kauai is so
unflappable and because he's so good
what kind of impact does he have good
what kind of impact does he have on this
entire group in games like this in
venues like this I think I've said it in
many a way and you know his demeanor has
kind of you know taken a big part of our
team and you know we have some guys that
are fiery and feisty but that are fiery
and feisty but you know we all kind of
just stay level-headed and never get too
up never get too down and you know
series can tell you the true
professionals guys that just been you
know continuing to work and work hard
and even our guys that aren't planned
they come in there they get shots up
they play that they come in there they
get shots up they play it through round
three nicotine you to be ready and you
know that's a good testament to our team
and you know with the demeanor that we
have Kawhi definitely brought a lot to
that him and Danny you know they kind of
definitely brought a lot to that second
row in this corner Harvey Jones posted
us all you all been through a lot to get
to this other video games again
man just hard work you know we put a lot
work and we believe in us the one with
one good thing about us you know our
toughness mind toughness you know we we
be getting better and better each wound
first one second one third one and now
we're here you know so and now we're
here you know so you know like how to
say I say we always try to be ready you
know even the guy who don't play they
come out you know put in work even
myself and Mark you know when you play
last minute you come the next day you
come the next day you know you put in
work so I think that's one of the only
thing about us or so nice because we
always try to be ready Steve on the
right nba.com Kyle from from night to
night are there things that from night
to night
are there things that Serge shows you or
says that lets you know he's he's going
to be a factor offensively or is it
simply you and your teammates sort of
bringing that out of him I don't know he
doesn't say anything I don't think
I think surges when Serge is effective
defensively the scoring just comes you
know we want to make sure he gets that
take a pop jump shot he's rolling
but when Serge is that as best as on
that defensive end and well he brings
that intense event and well he brings
that intensity and that fierceness you
know it's kind of tough to stop him on
both ends of the floor you know it makes
a lot of a big difference when it when
he can come when he can do that hi Jana
policy key eagle news when it
collectively as a team to collect
yourselves when you see one of your main
players go down like that
oh we do try to stay together you know
we just stood together at that moment
you know we just stood together at that
moment he's nothing we can do he's you
know we're just hoping like he can come
back and help us last question towards
the news of news bus can be Africa I
gotcha
alright thank you
definitely answer that tattoos Emma or
finale in beyond Korea or to Vasya in
Victoire our duty to Allah obey on
Jessica Slava present port want uncle
fist soju Congo feast Africa for marking
off East Africa for massa power more for
my personal moments vamos a pelear
junkie legend aqui new team Oregon a
freak Lejeune NBA hosiery basket Marley
poster policy department personnel a
mark on to succumb face you to my Pascal
to confer a on fess up or last week
people a junkie new regard qua don't see
selling sample mardonale examp duodenal
example thank you quietly up next
you